king in the sting jack coming to you
from northampton massachusetts
uh lesbian capital of the country huge
fan
and i got a debate club for you guys
who is the worst tweeter
could it be being dad or would it be
ruth conda forever mom
if you're unfamiliar i sent my man nick
some screenshots
i know about bean
forever it was here we go uh what a
weird question
this guy interesting though it's
interesting but so very specific for the
listener i know bean dad
has a daughter i guess he's a podcast
like musician guy
and so he has a daughter and she wanted
to open up beans
and then he was like well you need to
figure out how to do it on your own with
the
can opener right and it took her six
hours which is alarming
took her six hours she's 12 or something
nine nine nine
took her like six hours she was starving
she was crying and throwing fits
yeah and he was like well you need to
figure this out this is life yeah
he sounds fun yeah he sounds like a
great sounds like a real problem i think
my problem she'll be on like she'll be
like doing [ __ ] on she'll be on only
fans in four years
selling her [ __ ] for [ __ ] you know
adderall and he'll be like i don't know
where i went wrong i
i spent nine hours watching my problem
is what kind of dad thinks it's smart to
go on twitter and tell everyone what you
did yeah and then he apologized
which is also the worst thing you could
do though i actually apologize so just
told my friend so this is the what kind
of mom
just told my 10 year old daughter about
uh rbg who passed away she had tears in
her eyes and then
she did the wakanda pose and said ruth
conda forever which is sort of popcorn
now this woman's worse
oh wow yes she's worse this woman's
muscle she's not even a question
no she yeah this woman [ __ ] sucks
dude that first of all your ten-year-old
daughter that never happened you made
this entire situation entire thing
up i i like uh hillary baldwin better
than this lady
yeah this lady sucks hilarious we call
it hillary
okay are you a fan of hilarious she's
from north florida i'm all for it
pretend to be a different race i think
it's great who cares
does that bother you what kind of loser
are you if somebody came up to me
they're like do you know this [ __ ]
isn't really russian i'd go
oh yeah i don't care i don't give a [ __ ]
she likes russians yeah all right she
wants to speak in russia
i don't understand why people get upset
about this [ __ ] i think it's great
i think it's fun i don't know why people
are mad i don't give a [ __ ] i think she
also was doing she was like a high-class
hispanic lady she wasn't trying to she's
not an ms-13
she's not like trying to be a [ __ ]
gangbanger no she was on good morning
america yeah [ __ ]
trying to say she's trying to be white
plus yes white with a little spice
to me is fine to separate herself from
the masses i would get it it would be a
little weird if she was trying to be a
maid
you know like she's like alec balder's
wife hilaria pretending to be a maid and
she was like
you know like that would be weird i
guess where he gets dice is alex baldwin
met her in a restaurant
and she's pretending she's spanish and
doesn't know who he is
he's like i'm not from here i don't know
who you are
well he's also a psychopath right so i
mean who does he think he's attracted
but also
when they lay down at night because
they've been together for like [ __ ]
12 years
he you know damn well he was like oh
this [ __ ] isn't from spain
come on man right no he's punched her in
the face
he's definitely hit her but this uh
alexandra lee caps is by far the worst
she's cause she made this entire thing
up
uh but then people started digging into
john roderick was the bean dad guy
and he had a bunch of like anti-semitic
tweets and stuff uh this one right here
uh he replied to someone who said the
fourth has been perverted by
activist uh jew and mud people apologist
now it's heating up yeah that's not even
really a joke
no that's pure racism that's real hate
that's a philosophy yeah that's bad now
he's also best friends with the guy from
uh
jeopardy who is also taking some heat
for saying some racist tools
uh he's he's uh jennings he does a
podcast with ken jennings uh and then
yeah some people like
ken jennings has like off color tweets
nothing like that no like no there's no
humor in there
his was about gays and um
and uh uh mentally this guy deleted his
twitter
john roderick he got rid of his twitter
he had another one
he said uh and i'm quoting him uh i
object to
people who say or the for to the people
who say
object when i say gay or [ __ ] it
just reminds me how
gay and [ __ ] they are that's tough
or how they're gay retards or something
yeah that's i mean that's just kind of a
stupid thing he's good he's good at
jeopardy
shoes like that that's a little wild
yeah
yeah too much so are we leaning back
towards bean dad is the worst
no no no still the mockery made the
entire situation up
and then decided to go to twitter to get
likes yeah no she's still worse
[Music]